The Joe Rogan experience.
Yeah. Well, that's a good move because people are tired of Trump jokes.
You know, it's one of those subjects. People like enough already.
Man. I've been tired of them. And now I'm like they coming back around,
they'll come in to be frustrated,
to be frustrated when to do this on his way out, you know,
it doesn't make no sense. It's like he is still getting to you. You know,
it's just a matter of time. If you want to say the people,
the voice of the peoples was heard. It was a close situation,
but it is what it is. And he's gone.
Oh man,
people have some legitimate gripes and I understand where they're coming from.
But my perspective is it's not changing anything and it's not doing you any
good to still be holding on your,
if you are an anti-Trump Biden's seat. I mean,
I don't think it's 99% official, right? I mean, they just haven't said it yet.
And they, when they say it, then he will be become president.
And then Kamel Harris will be the new vice-president.
So concentrate on good voters. Now it's over. Right.
But people are so obsessed.
The other day. I might've said this earlier.
Look at Mike Pence and I'm having a meeting with no mess, man. Okay.
Why you still keep getting mad? Cause this don't have a mask on.
It's gotta be something else to do.
But this, they, they want to talk about negative things. That's the thing.
Some people get addicted to talking about negative things and they can't regroup
even after a victory. And now focus on positive things.
They want to continue to focus on negative things.
And I can see their perspective too. Especially with all these crazy tweets.
Like I won that election, you know, it's all fraud. It's all this.
It's all that like, man,
if you've got some real claims now I don't know what the claims are.
I haven't really honestly investigated them. But if you've got some real claims,
you got to present the evidence and then once you present the evidence,
you say all the stuff like I got robbed, I really want it.
If you want to be in a position where you're respected,
if you're the president of the United States, this isn't a regular guy.
It's not like if you were involved in some ridiculous,
like small neighborhood election and you were joking around on Twitter,
I won that election. That's that's that's to be expected.
But when someone's in a position where they're in charge of the nuclear football
club, it's literally are the commander chief of the greatest army in the world.
No. You're saying like that and firing people that don't agree with it. Yeah.
From up did like, I know these other places, like what?
This would be a great time for a terrorist attack right now.
Well, one of the guys he fired what the guy said was he didn't believe there was
widespread voter fraud. And he's like, you're fired.
If you don't believe that you're fired. Like this is, this is like a madman.
The interesting part for me is like you try and to
switch the thoughts of a person that is a huge Trump
fan. It's a waste of,
it's only going to be the only thing you're going to be as frustrated.
Here's the thing though. I don't know. And this is where it's really important.
I don't know exactly how the election went
down in terms of like,
was there like 0.01% fraud was,
was there 0.5%? How much fraud was there?
We gotta assume that when there's people counting stuff,
there's some fuckery going on.
Yeah.
But the fuckery that's been reported as bit light still no more than like 40
people, bro. And then the only other.
Problem is that it's all done through these machines. Right?
And then there's been all these conspiracy theories about
machines that were supposed to have been giving the votes to Trump,
gave those boats to Biden. Now I could repeat those things,
but I don't know if they're true.
But I don't know what I do. Know what I'm saying? I do know. I know Georgia.
I know the pulled all them envelopes up to the built-in and they cut
them open and they took a man by hand. They did them hand by hand yo, those,
those ones that were recounts or whatever, those you can't,
it's no machine that is hand by hand. Right? It's problem.
How does that work? Did they have someone watch while they do it? Like,
do they have a supervisor?
Because I would imagine you would want to have like almost like two people watch
while one person does it, which is so ridiculous. But it seems like you kind of,
if you don't trust.
People, I know you don't trust me, but you kind.
Of have to have someone watching it.
That's part of the argument that Trump's administration was saying too,
was that there were certain counts that they weren't allowed to observe.
They had to be really far away and they couldn't actually see.
That sounds like people that like soy beans, but that's the first,
that's the first soy boy attitude.
But what if you're telling the truth? Here's the thing I don't know.
And you don't know either.
So if they were telling the truth and people were counting votes incorrectly,
or.
They find no evidence of that every time that every time that they came out with
all these losses in the jaw, dropping them,
dropping them because there's no evidence of it. He's probably made he's.
He's had to have made every argument he can make.
No, listen, I agree with you. I agree with you.
There's no evidence that they can present.
That's going to show people right now that there was so much voter
fraud that they got to return everything and start all over or they got to give
it to Trump. I agree with you.
I think this is what all these experts are saying.
They're all saying that even if there was voter fraud,
it wasn't enough to tilt the election one way or another,
but I don't know how these machines work. So if I'm even commenting on it,
if I'm saying they couldn't have done it, that's ridiculous.
I'm saying they must have done it. That's just as ridiculous.
I really don't know. That's like when you're talking about voting,
you're talking about how many millions of people are voting and all this
information is coming in and they got to sort it out.
You're going to some mistakes. There's no way around it. But the question is,
does it overall balance out or are there mistakes all for one
side, if you find out that mistakes are all for Biden, then you're going to go,
huh? Really well,
who owns the company that makes the machines and then who,
how are they financed and who programmed that? And how are they programmed?
Is it possible to with the data? It is possible. Can you show me how to do it?
You can do it. So
everybody wants to know exactly what happened. I think,
but I know a few people that know exactly what happened.
I know the machines and all that type of,
but when they take the machines away and they say, okay, we're counting these.
And by hand, the results of that have to be official. Yeah.
Well they understand like the machines, but they was like,
these melon was they, they had to count every vote.
Yeah. It's a matter of how they're recording it. Right.
You would want to make sure that everybody recorded it accurately.
I don't know how they do it. But I would imagine that when I,
when I was talking to a guy like Mike Baker and he was saying that even if there
was fraud, there's not enough fraud to overturn it.
I would imagine he knows some things. Yeah. I don't,
I'm a moron. So me talking about, he w we all do that. You know, we talk about,
he won. She won and there's no way there was fraud, or it was definitely fraud.
Or I think Trump won by a landslide. Like people get, they get real,
um, connected.
They get real connected to who's who's winning or losing this election.
And I get it.
Man. I'm going Ms. Donald Trump, sir. Yo, I like not going anywhere, man. TV,
bad, man. I been missing him on TV. This is TV.
Persona is what sucks. What sucks that it's his TV persona is like,
he's a TV.
It sucks that it's even possible that someone could monkey with an
election to the point where you change the outcome.
It sucks that that's even a thought that we could get into our head.
That's what's one of the crazy things about people were so nuts.
But if we believe in a side,
like people that are good people we'll do some shady to have their candidate
win. Yeah, for sure. That's politics.
We're so crazy.
That's politics. Anything goes, anything goes.
What bothers me? And I do think that Biden won the election.
And I do think that, I mean, I think there's probably some shenanigans,
but I think the result is most likely correct,
but it bothers me that there's even a question.
It bothers me that anyone would ever think that anyone could fail.
But I think that there's Republicans, the Democrats could do it.
And I think there's Democrats that think Republicans can do it. And I think
it's, it's going to be real hard to 100% trust the election.
That's one of the things that's kind of dangerous about someone going after it.
This election is rigged the selections rig when Trump is doing that,
he's encouraging P and you know, maybe that's a good thing if they are rigged,
because maybe they're going to be able to figure out how to stop that from
happening in the future. Or maybe it's going to road,
or maybe it's going to road people's confidence in the elections.
And the more he does it, the mortar roads and the market's dangerous.
There's a real argument for that too. But it looks, and again, I'm,
I don't know what the I'm talking about.
Episodes of the Joe Rogan experience are now free on Spotify. That's right.
They're free from September 1st to December 1st,
they're going to be available everywhere, but after December 1st,
they will only be available on Spotify, but they will be free.
That includes the video. The video will also be there. It'll also be free.
That's all we're asking you. Just go download Spotify much. Buh-bye.
Okay.